[موسيقى]
الملاحظاتي الشخصيه هنا في موسكو والتحدث
مع الاشخاص
اليهم اقول بان المزاج في روسيا ايضا الان
مختلف عن ما كان عليه في العمل الماضي في
العمل الماضي كانوا اكثر خوفا وتشككا وحتى
غاضبين احيانا ما حصل
ومتخوفين ما سيحصل اما الان فاستطيع ان
اقول بين المزاج اصبح فيه تحدي اكبر
الاحساس القومي ويرون بلا شك ان هذا
النزاع الان على انه حرب بين روسيا وبين
الناتو وبين روسيا والغرب
انتقل بعيدا عن مجرد حرب في اوكرانيا فبات
الشعب يرى ان اوكرانيا تحارب من اجل
بقائها وهكذا تغير المزاج والان هم
مستعدون لتحمل المزيد من الصعوبات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وبصراحه الى الان
لم يواجهوا الكثير منها ولكن ان حصلت فسوف
يتحملونها لانهم يشعرون بان بلادهم مهدده
وبالتالي فهذا شيء عليهم
يتحملهم من اجل بقاء بلادهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الان مختلف تماما ولهم كثيره من العزيمه
والاصرار والعناد والكثير من القوميه
فاخشى ان لم يكن هنالك اي انجاز سياسي فلا
ارى ان الحكومه ادرسيه سترغم لا اقتصاديا
او بسبب العقوبات او حتى بسبب الراي العام
المحلي لا ارى انها سترغم على عكس قرارها
والخروج من اوكرانيا تحت اي ظروف معقوله
لفتره طويله جدا واذا ما انتهت الحرب
سيكون ذلك بسبب اتفاق سياسي مع الغرب ولن
يكون بسبب العقوبات الاقتصاديه او الضغوط
المحليه في روسيا
[موسيقى]